today of course is Super Tuesday many of
the votes did you know this many of the
votes for Super Tuesday were cast by
u.s. mail did you know that yeah which
means we will never know the results
ever we will spend the rest of our lives
and never know now did you male energy
voters by mail for the first time I'm
like why have I not been doing this all
along it was so easy I went to the
voting they have a modern but did anyone
use the modern California voting machine
today wow I don't know what's going this
is important [ __ ] what is wrong with you
people you spent the whole day going to
TV tapings we were Wheel of Fortune we
couldn't make it there's a modern
machine where you feed a piece of paper
in and you put in all your votes and
then it takes you put it out and it
shows it to you and then you feed it
back in again and it shreds it I just
fought for a minute I was afraid it was
going to be yeah that's how that's how
you vote now it's not very cool it's
very interesting
speaking of voting many Bloomberg I'm
sorry Minnie Bloomberg I've had a lot to
drink that's what I do on Super Tuesday
Michael Bloomberg did you hear this he
spent 36 million dollars on ads in
California alone yes in fact when I was
watching TV last night a Bloomberg ad
popped up in the middle of a Bernie
Sanders ad that's how run out of his
forehead it came out of his forehead
Mike Bloomberg and then he ran away
not not a large man analysts say
Democrats are now circling the wagons
around Joe Biden that's the phrase yeah
by and said the last time wagons were
circled around me I was five and monpa
were headed to Oregon Territory
good old dad that's the applause of an
audience that's saying let's move it
along
oh I couldn't read you guys they okay
that's enough yeah what else you got
what else you got keep going there